- Recently someone asked me
what the most important element
of a business slide presentation is.
And after thinking about it for a bit,
it was very clear to me
that Action Titles are actually
the most important elements.
So by now you're not really
sure what an Action Title is,
or how to come up with a very,
very strong Action Title,
welcome come to another video here
on my channel "Firm Learning".
My name is Heinrich, I'm a
former McKinsey consultant,
and on my channel I
talk a lot about topics
such as career success,
and also consulting skills.
And surely as a consultant,
one thing that you really need to do well,
is to create slide presentations,
in PowerPoint or any of
these other programs.
So in today's video,
I want to sharpen your understanding
why Action Titles are so important,
and also give you some
very, very tangible tips,
including an exercise to help you come up
with the best possible Action Titles
that you can write for your slides.
Let's start by looking into
why Action Titles are so important.
And the key point you're to understand,
is that your presentations
should have a storyline.
And it is the Action Titles
that bring this story to life.
The main idea is that
if you read your titles
of your presentation,
from start to end,
so every single slide
just read the titles.
The key idea is that by just doing that,
you will be able to understand
all the key messages
of the presentation just by
reading these Action Titles.
So why is this even necessary?
Why is this important?
Well try to put yourself into the shoes
of a C level manager,
you are a CEO, CFO, any
other business unit head,
any other senior guy in an organization.
Likely especially these
large blue chip companies
that often these consulting
firms we work for,
these C level people,
every single day, every single week,
they will get several big
documents, 50 pages, 100 pages,
or even more of other
projects that are going on.
Project updates, progress
reports, deliverables like that.
This is far too much to read.
People like this cannot
just read every single slide
of documents like that.
So what they will expect you
to deliver as a document,
where they can just skim through,
just read the Action Titles,
and just by reading the Action Titles,
be able to understand
all the key messages.
And this is the so-called
horizontal logic,
the storyline of the presentation,
this needs to come to life,
via the Action Titles.
And then the idea is of course,
that if they read something
in the Action Title,
that is really interesting,
where they want to learn more about,
then they stop, and
then they read the page,
they read the full slide.
This then is the vertical logic.
And you of course,
you already understand one key thing
when writing strong Action Titles.
And this is that of
course an Action Title,
should summarize the contents of a slide
in a clear and concise way.
So this is the intuition,
but now you might ask yourself,
well, what exactly is an Action Title?
So I try to put down here in definition.
This is coming from myself.
So no fancy source,
just my best way of putting it in writing.
And I would define an Action Title
by being a header of a slide presentation,
that summarizes the content of the slide,
by formulating a complete sentence.
So if you wanted something
like here, the header,
also here on top of this slide saying,
Action Titles have to
create your storyline
within a presentation.
This would be the Action
Title of that slide.
This is what you want to try to achieve.
But what do you write in such a title?
What are the contents supposed to be?
And here I think the best
test that you can do,
is the test of the so called, so what?
The question of the, so what?
And a one screen of full video
just about the concept of
asking this question, so what?
I will link it somewhere above here
if you're interested to learn
more about this feel free
to check it out.
But in a nutshell,
the so what is a question,
that you as a project lead,
might ask to an associate, a
consultant to prepare the slide
or maybe a partner asked to you.
And this person looks at your slide,
and asks him or herself
the question, so what?
Right? So, so what?
Why is this irrelevant?
What is the implication
of what I see here?
Because maybe the information
on the slide is interesting,
it's data, it's nice,
but what does this mean
for the problem at hand?
For the thing that I need to solve?
So when putting together the document,
you should ask yourself,
what is the so what on the slide?
If already you struggle to
come up with the so what,
then this often is a sign
that this slide maybe isn't
that important, right?
If it does not have a clear so what?
Maybe it's something that
rather belongs in the appendix
but maybe not in the main deck
or maybe take it out completely.
But once you know the so what?
Make sure that the so
what is clearly stated
in the Action Title,
and then of course, when
you are presenting the slide
then the so what is also what
you should be communicating
in your presentation.
Now let's look into a
couple of best practices
that you should apply whenever
you write an Action Title.
And here we'll always have an example,
and then an insight that I
wanna draw out from that.
The first example is,
"Managing risk is important
for this project's success".
And here my answer is, try to
avoid statements like that.
Try to avoid writing general truths,
that are pretty much always correct.
So of course, managing risks
is pretty much always important
for this project's success, right?
So for almost every project
that would be relevant.
So try to avoid writing
things that are obvious,
really draw out more
insightful things than that.
Next, something like,
"All divisions have found
to not be following best practices".
What's often dangerous,
is to write Action Titles
with really hard absolute statements,
always never in every case,
this is like this or like that.
So these very hard statements,
often are traps
because there are often
some weird edge cases.
Maybe there is this, like very
little division somewhere,
who does something that
you are not aware of.
Just my personal learning,
that often then especially
if you're presented,
maybe there is like one board
member sitting in the audience
who will tell you,
no, but this is not correct.
This is wrong.
'Cause you know, it's
just enough of one example
that contradicts this,
and then pretty much you're
there, need to admit that,
yes, your message was wrong,
what you put on the slide was wrong.
It's not the case, that this
is true for all divisions.
Next one.
"Company has potential to
significantly improve profit".
So here my learning from that is,
try to whenever possible to
quantify the Action Titles.
Include numbers in the Action Titles.
So if you make a slide
about profit of a company
usually you should always
be able to support a number.
So what is the profit
improvement potential?
What is the potential for the profit
that you see in the company?
Next one.
"When conducting data
analysis and interviews,
"we learnt a lot about the business".
So this would be an Action Title
which very much focuses on the process.
So what you did, you analyzed
data, conducted interviews,
you learned a lot.
This is often not so relevant.
People don't really
care to who you talk to,
what analysis you conducted,
what people are interested
in are the results.
This is one of the key
fundamental principles
of top down communication.
Again, I don't wanna go too
deep into this in this video
but I will link another video that I did
about top down communication, about fear,
check it out, really one of
the most fundamental concepts
for communication as a
consultant but also in general,
in any professional environment.
Last example here,
"Results indicate significant potential
"to look into further improvement
measures for the business
"with the goal to increase profits by 50%
"until end of this financial
year for the company".
So frankly I don't even know
what exactly this means.
The point that I wanted to make here is,
write Action Titles in a concise way.
Don't use more words than necessary.
Yes, usually there will
be a full sentence,
but don't just write
for the sake of writing.
The rule is that usually, in the title,
you should not have more
than two lines of titles.
So two lines are fine, but
not right more than two.
Now let's put your Action Title
writing abilities to test.
You see here a standard slide,
it's from a mock up presentation.
Of course not any actual line engagement,
but what you see here is a slide
where the Action Title is missing.
And I want now you to come
up, with an Action Title.
And now to help a little bit out here
we just like briefly
expand what you see here.
So here you see a sizing
of a growth potential,
EBIT potential for this company
that could choose to enter these market.
So the North America market,
or the Asia Pacific market,
and then you see different
numbers, you see the market size,
you see how much of the market
is covered by competitors,
the current market share,
and other considerations like this,
and in the end, also an EBIT potential,
that the company could receive
from entering these markets.
Now I would encourage you
to maybe even pause
the video for a moment,
and think about for yourself,
what would be a strong Action Title,
for such a slide.
If you want even write it down.
So let's look at the couple of examples
of what you could have written.
So the first is,
"Derived potentials for an expansion".
And again, feel free to always pause
and think about this for yourself,
whether you consider
that this is a strong Action Title or not.
Because indeed I would argue,
this is not even an Action Title.
This does not even meet the
definition of an Action Title.
This is a title in the style
that I know many people like to do it,
but it's just not what I
would recommend you to do.
And this is for instance
if you have a page that
describes the risks
of a certain strategy,
then just writing risks
in the title, right?
So it's a title, but
it's not an Action Title
in the sense that,
it doesn't summarize the key message
of a slide in a full sentence.
Next one.
"Expand into new geographies
"creates a positive EBIT potential".
EBIT by the way, for the
uninitiated stands for,
Earnings Before Interest and Tax,
and pretty much is one
metric of profit, right?
So what is the profit, the
profit potential of the company.
So what do you think
about this Action Title?
And to you I would argue that
yes, it meets the definition.
I mean, it is an Action Title
following the definition,
but I would argue it's
not the best Action Title
that you could write.
Because indeed this seems far too generic.
You could be much more tangible,
much more concrete here.
But let's look into a
couple of other examples.
"Expansion to North
America and Asia Pacific,
"creates a positive EBIT potential".
I mean, yes, I like it.
It's a bit more rich of information.
You're not just talking about geographies
but are really mentioning
geographies you're interested in
but, here quantify if possible.
We just looked at these best practices.
Whenever possible,
especially whenever you
have numbers available
at your disposal,
put them in the Action
Title and quantify it.
Next one.
"Expansion to North
America and Asia Pacific
"creates a positive EBIT
potential of 22 Euro million".
So yes, here I would argue,
it's fine, it's already a very strong
and solid Action Title,
though here you could argue
that this is still a little bit too wordy.
You could write this in
a bit more concise way.
Usually, the fewer words
you use, the better.
So here one example,
"Expansion to North
America and Asia Pacific
"with 22 Euro million EBIT potential".
And I would argue that,
yes, this is a good
and solid Action Title.
You know, what's also
important to understand,
is then you wanna write
these Action Titles,
you do not need to write
them like you would write
like proper full sentences in a book.
It's completely fine to
take out certain words,
often you take out articles,
any other filler words,
which are not absolutely necessary
to understand the key messages.
Obviously you would probably
not write something like this
as a full sentence in a book.
But here's a concise Action
Title, this is absolutely fine.
So hope this makes sense to you.
So I know that in the
Firm Learning community
there are many other people
who are also quite experienced
with Action Titles.
So if you have any tips or insights
or other comments on this video,
please leave a comment below
in the comment section,
and trust that we would all
very much appreciate that.
Maybe you've already noticed
that this is a remake
of a video that I did,
as one of my very first
videos on this channel.
I just felt like the video back then,
was not really up to
the level of the quality
that I do the videos today,
and the topic is just so important
that I just wanted to
do an update on that.
Hope you still found it interesting
also if you've already
watched this quiet old video,
and if you've watched it,
thank you for watching "Firm
Learning" for that long.
I would never have thought
that I'd grow to the
point that I do right now,
when I started in January, 2020.
Thank you for being here
with me since the beginning.
As always,
if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please sit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to this channel
to say up to date on all my content.
If you want to see more from me
I also create content for
LinkedIn, Instagram, TikTok
and Twitch,
links to these socials
in the video description,
there you can also sign
up for my email newsletter
and of course last but not least,
the big, big thanks,
to all the members of the channel.
You're really making a
difference for "Firm Learning",
thank you so much.
My name is Heinrich,
I release videos every single Saturday,
so see you again next
week, until then, bye bye.